oh yeah it's the best of the videogame
movies not sure that's saying much the
Prince of Persia the sands of time
okay so Disney's been trying to recreate
that whole fluke Pirates of the
Caribbean Smash Hits summer blockbuster
movie thing pretty much ever since
Pirates of the Caribbean came out and
the bold truth of the matter is they're
never ever gonna do it ever again they
didn't do with the last two Pirates of
the Caribbean movies but their latest
attempt is a movie adaptation of the
videogame the Prince of Persia at the
sands of time and I'm gonna straight up
level with you guys I have never played
the Prince of Persia the sands of time
game The Last Prince of Persia game that
I played was on the battery munching
beast of a bastard known as The Game
Gear oh you know you remember so the
story goes - Don played by Jake
Gyllenhaal was adopted by the king of
Persia when he was a young Street orphan
so now he's a prince you guessed it of
Persia just think like Aladdin meets
Moses with a time reversing dagger and
after the Persians who were actually the
good guys in this movie sack a city
looking for weapons yeah you go ahead
and try that with the Spartans
they're douchebags
Gaston finds a dagger that when
activated will turn back time one minute
and thus the whole quest to help the
princess keep that dagger out of the
hands of the douchebag starts now the
beginning of this movie is pretty badass
you see Gyllenhaal is pretty much in
nobody when it comes to military
strength but he's all nimble like ninja
badass and he shows off his skills
throughout the movie it makes for a
pretty good be it uneven time at the
chemistry between Gyllenhaal and
princess hotness and that's gonna be her
name for this review because I really
don't remember her name from the movie
their chemistry isn't good or bad it
just kind of is I mean it's the classic
formula they don't like each other in
the beginning of the movie and then
throughout their quest they start to
grow close and start liking each other
by the end they love each other or
something there is a part where the
world's gonna end and they stop to
embrace a slow-motion kiss I didn't
really buy that I'm not gonna lie the
world was ending it might not have been
the time but I am NOT gonna live
flirtatious sarcastic banter beats the
living out of grade-b really forced
pseudo Shakespearean that
Anakin and Padme forcing our throats for
two movies Alfred Molina was in it I
loved him in the movie he was awesome
kind of feels like a really prolonged
cameo but it just goes to show you that
you don't need a lot of screen time to
steal the show every scene he was in he
was the man and was it me or was this
movie edit
really weird like there was a scene
where this guy was walking down a
hallway and and daggers fly by his head
and he kind of looks surprised and then
it fades to a hallway shot and he's
walking on a hallway again like it never
happened
this is one of many examples it's really
weird though now the coolest part in the
movies when Gyllenhaal activates the
dagger and the dagger turns back time
those scenes are badass but I was just
hoping to see more turning back time
moments I mean I don't even care man
spam that handle just turn back time
every four minutes I'd be happy but we
only get four of them in the entire
movie so this movie had a really cool
premise I had really cool moments the
on-screen romance it's not too bad
probably because princess hotness is hot
it had some nice action it's not a deep
movie but it'll keep you entertained I
mean it's just not the movie of the
summer or anything like that for me was
just kind of par for the course for the
movies this summer I mean it's
definitely worth a matinee watch I think
any more than that I don't know about
that so fun time just not a monumental
time we're still counting down the days
to inception and if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more then
click here to see more videos
[Music]